let me add one more on on top of the
pile of the worst case analysis so what
people talk about which is hurricanes
and earthquakes does is there a
connection that's well understood
between climate change
and uh the increased frequency and
intensity of hurricanes and earthquakes
I've dug in on both a lot the earthquake
connection to climate change I'm not
worried about compared to just the
earthquake risk that we live with in
many parts of the world already the
Himalayas
even with that earthquake in 2015 in
Kathmandu
that whole range is overdue for major
earthquakes and what has happened in the
last 50 years since they last had big
earthquakes huge development big cities
a lot of informal construction like the
stuff I wrote about in Istanbul where
the family builds another layer and
another they put a floor on every time
someone gets married has a kid you put
another floor in the house and
unfortunately that's you know
the what was the term this Turkish um
engineer
Rubble in waiting
it's rubble and waiting and we're
looking at it you know videotaping it
and there are people playing there so I
don't worry about the earthquake
connection to climate change
the Hurricanes I've written about for
decades um
and the most Illuminating body of
science
that I've dug in on literally
related hurricanes is this field that's
emerged gets a tiny bit of money
compared to like climate modeling it's
called paleo tempestology
it's like paleontology you know they
look for evidence of past hurricanes
long coasts that we care about
and they dig down into the lagoons
behind like the barrier beaches along
Florida or the Carolinas or in Puerto
Rico
and what you have is a history book of
past hurricanes so there's this mud mud
mud mud mud mud mud mud made of
accumulating over centuries and then
there's a layer of sand
and seashells and what that indicates is
that there was a great storm that came
across the beach pushed a lot of
sediment into the mud and then there's
and when you look at that work I first
wrote about this in 2001 in the times in
a long story and then
kept track of these Intrepid scientists
putting these core tubes down it shows
you we're in a landscape where big bad
hurricanes are
not they're the norm but
something that's rare and big is
something that's extreme when you think
about the word extreme right it means
it's at the end of the spectrum of
what's possible
they're rare
rare in human time scales
um hurricane Michael four years ago
devastated category five came ashore in
the panhandle of Florida
leveled that much photographed Town
Mexico Beach
and um people are actually the
Tallahassee National Weather Service
said unprecedented
hurricane
and the damage was unprecedented because
there hadn't been a community there
before
but the hurricane was not unprecedented
at all if you look at the history and
this is published research it's just
that no one bothers to
we have this blind spot for um
the longer time scale you need to
examine if you're thinking about big bad
things that are rare and hurricanes are
still rare I was recently covering Fort
Myers the awful devastation
there's a young climate scientist at
Florida Gulf Coast University Joe Muller
who's done that paleo tempestology work
there right in Fort Myers she lives
there and she was away in London at a
meeting of reinsurance companies that
reinsured all the world's big bad risks
when this was happening but she has done
the work that shows uh it's a
Thousand-Year record of past hurricanes
and it's super sobering
when you consider how fast people have
moved into
Florida and built vulnerably in an area
that hurricanes will Hammer that it part
of the fundamental dynamics of the Gulf
of Mexico and these storms come off of
Africa
it's a place where they would come now
the question of global warming impact is
subtle there are aspects of hurricanes
that haven't changed there's aspects
like rainfall that seem pretty
powerfully linked to global warming
a warmer atmosphere holds more moisture
so when you have a big disturbance like
a the heat engine of a hurricane comes
through it you get more rain
this rapid intensification you know how
quickly these storms
jump from like you know category one to
five or four before they hit
isn't is a new area of science so I
think it's still early days and knowing
because no one was looking for that
there were no data back 300 years ago
you know when these big bad previous
hurricanes came to know whether they
were rapidly intensified or not so I as
a journalist I try to
you know keep track of what we don't
know not to be too constrained and
think about new science as being
you know robust unless it's considering
and actually actively stating
we don't really know what's going on
with earlier Harkins
and all of that is swamped ultimately
literally
by the vulnerability building
vulnerability in these areas you know if
there's a marginal change in a storm
and you've quadrupled or sex tupled
how much stuff and how many people are
in the way
and if some of those people are poor and
vulnerable
or elderly and can't swim
you're creating a landscape of
Destruction so a lot of the human
suffering that has to do with storms is
about where and how you build
versus the frequency and the intensity
of storms still you didn't quite answer
okay the question
uh you know when I'm having a beer with
people at a bar and they say hey why are
you having a beer we're all going to die
because of climate change usually what
they bring up
uh and I'm just trying to add some
leaves no this is good usually what they
bring up is you know the hurricanes and
the most recent hurricanes saying like
this they're getting crazy hurricanes
all the time they're getting more
intense more frequent and so on as is
there I'm sure there's incredible signs
going on trying to look at this uh is
there is it possible is there evidence
and is it possible to have evidence that
there's a connection
between what would we can call Global
Warming and the increased frequency and
intensity of Storms and is okay no thank
you uh
you're added intensity you know it's
it's let me just get into this a tiny
bit more I mean hurricanes
I grew up with them in Rhode Island in
the new and you know in my youth and
there was a very active period of
hurricanes in New England
in the 50s and 60s 70s
and then in the North Atlantic generally
was very very active number 50 when I
was a kid and
the Dynamics of them forming off of
Africa and coming here circling up the
coast was just prime time
then there was like what Kerry Emanuel
who's the most experienced hurricane
climate scientist around at MIT
I he was in he's in this story he's in
he's in my 1988 article
he and colleagues have found and others
that
was what they call the hurricane drought
from like the 70s through about 1994. in
the Atlantic specifically the Atlantic
basin
and there's been a lot of questions
about that people thought it was ocean
circulation something about the currents
do these multi-decatal
variabilities in the oceans right
and then now it looks robustly I can't
find a climate scientist who disagrees
that the thing that caused the drought
was pollution smog
and significantly in Europe and you say
well how did smog in Europe relate to
hurricanes
crossing the Atlantic and getting to
the United States it's because of the
smog was changing the behavior of the
Sahara Desert which is just south of
Europe
and and the Sarah Harrah desert kills
hurricanes sand and dust coming off the
Sahara you can see this every year when
that's active
stifles these big storms at the point
right in their Nursery they all form
there's this area for hurricanes off of
West Africa that's like the nursery
selling and so if you're stifling those
hurricanes because of pollution in in
Europe before the Clean Air acts kind of
you know cleanups and then that goes
away
none of that has anything to do with
global warming it's another kind of
forcing in the climate system a local
one that created a regional dynamic that
created a quiet period when all these
friends in the bar
we're maybe they maybe they were born
you know in the 90s or whatever they
grew up in an area of like you know
where no hurricanes weren't a big deal
um
and now we have an end to that drought
because we cleaned up the air pollution
the [ __ ] kind of air pollution sulfury
and
anyone who says global warming global
warming without saying well that's in
there too is kind of missing
that and when you look globally you know
there's still I think was it 90 or so
hurricanes a year to Cyclones hurricanes
typhoons globally that hasn't changed
the number of these tropical storms that
reach that ferocity has not changed it's
just a fundamental Dynamic of and and by
the way on the long time scale the
models
still indicate as you warm the planet
and remember the Arctic worms quicker
this is something people probably
understand
you're actually evening out the
imbalance between the Heat of the
Equator
and the cold at the the in the northern
part of the hemisphere
and that calms the whole system down so
there could be fewer hurricanes later in
the century because of global warming
and for me you know that's a lot of
information but if I'm in a bar
I start with what what do you care about
you care about safety you care about
security you care about
having everybody safe not just you you
get in your car and you can evacuate
what about the old person
you know or the poor family
who can't do that they're not going to
leave their house what are we doing to
limit vulnerability now that I Circle
back to that over and over again I have
like a pocket card I have this
graphic card I created about risk and
like what we really care about is
climate risk like who's at risk what's
driving the risk how do you reduce that
it's car you can almost pull it out in a
bar I should print them you should do
that it's like Risk risk is
risk is the hazard like you know the
hazard is
is a storm
times exposure how many people how much
stuff
factoring in
um vulnerability or resilience
and
climate change is changing the hazard
for some things not for tornadoes not
for not for everything
exposure is this expanding Bullseye this
is another hashtag expanding bullseye
get out there and look for that and
you'll see I I've pushing these two
geographers who do this for every Hazard
wildfire
earthquake flood Coastal storm and we're
building and expanding Bullseye in an
area and Nature's throwing darts some of
the darts are getting bigger because of
global warming some of the darts we
don't know
what do you do like what do you do well
you get out of the way right you don't
want to be on the dartboard and that it
just simplifies the whole formula
to me it was it's kind of a
transformational
uh potential
to go into a bar maybe I should print
these things 100 yeah with you more
often they should be coasters and bars
because that was fascinating about Smog
and I mean it's just it's nice to be
reminded about how complicated and
fascinating the weather system is let me
try to answer the the the questions
slightly quicker before your your
friends have drunk too much uh but never
enough
or not enough
um so if you look at the amount of uh of
uh the number of hurricanes as uh as
Andy brightly pointed out
um it doesn't look like it's changing so
we see more because we have now much
better detection systems with satellites
but if you look since uh uh 1980 when we
have good satellite coverage for
instance last year
was the year that had the lowest number
of hurricanes in the world
and you know you're sort of like that's
that's odd because it's probably the
year where I heard the most about
hurricanes and what that tells you is
that just because you hear a lot about
hurricanes doesn't actually mean that
there is a lot of hurricanes you can't
just go that way if if you remember uh
in the 1990s and 2000s uh there was an
enormous amount of talk about how
violence uh how crime was getting worse
in the U.S while all the objective
indicators showed that it was going down
but there's sufficient amount of
violence that you can fill every radio
and TV show with a new crime and so if
you get more and more TV shows that talk
about crime actually most people end up
thinking that there's more crime while
the real numbers going down so the
reality here is
yes climate change will probably affect
uh hurricanes in the sense that they'll
be the same number or slightly fewer as
Andy was mentioning but they will likely
be somewhat stronger this seems to be
the the best outcome we're not sure but
this seems to be the the outcome and
it's important to remember stronger is
worse than fewer is better
so overall
climate will make the world a little bit
worse so that's that's the that's the
sort of bottom line but and that's the
real issue here all the other things the
fact that people are much more
vulnerable is is just vastly outweigh
this which is why if you look at the
impact of hurricanes and impact of
pretty much everything is typically
going down if you look for instance in
percent of GDP you have to look at
percent of GDP because if you have twice
as many houses obviously you know the
same kind of impact will have twice the
the impact or if they're twice as worth
twice as much if you do that in percent
of GDP and even the UN says that's how
you should measure it's going down why
is that it's because we're becoming more
resilient you know just simply we you
know if you look at what happens with
when hurricanes come in we have much
better prediction in the long run that
means you now know you know two or three
days out that there's a big hurricane
that's likely to come here what does
that mean all the things that can be
moved so you know typically All Buses
all trucks everything that's not bolted
down we'll leave this area and so you'll
get less damage from that you will have
more people knowing oh this is going to
be a big one they move to their relative
somewhere else so you'll have fewer
people being vulnerable there's if
people are responsive and aware yeah
so the the outcome and this is important
for the whole conversation the outcome
is that we're actually becoming less
vulnerable and the damages are becoming
smaller not bigger but had they not been
global warming it would probably have
gone down even faster so we would have
become even better off quicker had there
been no global warming but this is a
crucial difference and this is what I
find really hard to communicate climate
change is not this oh my God everything
is going off the off the off the charts
and we're all going to be doomed kind of
thing climate change is a thing that
means we're going to get better slightly
slower and that's a very very different
kind of attitude it's one of the many
problems problems rather than this is
the end of all of us and by the way if
you look at what's happening in the
world
um the data also show that in rich
places and poor places we still are
moving into zones of Hazard faster than
climate is changing Beth Tillman
was at Columbia and she moved to Arizona
she and colleagues at this outfit called
Cloud to Street did an amazing study
showing this is a year or so ago I wrote
about showing
again we're moving into zones of Hazard
which it applies to me
um
just what Bjorn was saying that we
wouldn't be people wouldn't be doing
that if they thought that was going to
lead to Devastation and this is today
we're doing this now and it's flood
flood zones Wildfire zones
so that means there's these things to do
you this is so much plasticity in the
human behavior and how we build and
where we build you can make a big big
change in the outcomes I mean one of the
things to remember is you know people
move to where hurricanes hit because
when they're not there it's a really
beautiful place to be yeah yeah right so
so in in many ways we we make the
trade-offs and say look I'm I'm happy to
live you know have an ocean view and
then maybe a hurricane is going to hit
and of course it becomes a lot easier
than when the federal government is
actually subsidizing your risk by saying
we'll insure you really cheaply uh and
that's one of the things that we should
stop doing you know we should actually
tell people look if you want to live
where hurricanes sit maybe you should be
more careful and by the way what I was
saying about
um past storms the Paleo attempt
histology past fires it's the same thing
we've suppressed fire in the United
States for 100 years through much of the
west through uh wanting to save the
forests you know the whole Smokey the
Bear thing don't stop when these are
Landscapes that were that evolved to
burn
and what happened in the last hundred
years a lot of people love the West we
love we love these environments we love
to live with the trees the Boulder
County area the explosive development in
zones of implicit hazard leads to Big
Bad outcomes when conditions align and
climate change is worsening some of
those conditions and sometimes it's
really counterintuitive a wet season
builds more grass
dry season comes along parches the grass
then comes a human ignition it's almost
always human ignitions and then you have
this disaster where a thousand homes
burn in Boulder County and it's like
there's so many elements there that can
be worked on that give me confidence
that we can
change these outcomes you can natural
disasters are not natural disasters are
designed really some people say